well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages
in the next half hour or so then we will
see what's making the headlines
with the editor of the politico london
playbook alex wickham
and the editor-in-chief of open
democracy mary fitzgerald
super to have you both thorn great to
see you as ever though front pages first
of all starting with the guardian
it reveals that an ofsted request for
greater powers to investigate
abuse in private schools was rejected by
ministers
the metro reports a police watchdog has
found that officers
acted properly in dealing with the crowd
which gathered in south london for the
vigil to honor sarah everard
according to the daily telegraph the
leaders of france and germany have
spoken to vladimir putin
about acquiring some of russia's covet
vaccine stock
meanwhile the eye has spoken to one of
the co-creators
of the astrazeneca vaccine who says the
uk
does not have enough capacity to
manufacture vaccine doses
that's despite an announcement earlier
this week from novovax
the daily mirror leads on the
record-breaking march temperatures with
sun seekers urged to stick
to social distancing measures the daily
mail reports
on the major review into british society
which was commissioned
in the wake of the black lives matter
protests it finds the uk
is not an institutionally racist country
that is also the lead story for the
times diverse uk
hailed over narrowing of race cap their
headline
the sun meanwhile hears from retired
footballer thierry henry
about his decision to leave social media
owing in large part
to racist abuse and the financial times
leading with an investigation by
regulators into the sell-off of shares
in a capital management company to see
if any of the banks involved acted
inappropriately
so let's get the thoughts the choices of
alex wickham and mary fitzgerald uh
hello again to both of you
um and to the uh racism inquiry we go
first
um the two papers uh that we're leading
on are the daily mail and the telegraph
be interesting to see some of the other
newspapers take maybe when we get the
insides
but the daily mail says that this
landmark report
shows that the uk is in fact a model to
the world on diversity
and finds no evidence of institutional
racism
this may well go down rather
controversially tomorrow alex
absolutely this is definitely going to
be the main
news of the day uh in westminster
tomorrow it's the report
by the race and uh ethnic disparities
commission that was set up by boris
johnson in the wake of the black lives
matter movement last summer
which reports tomorrow and has
some really quite eye-catching
conclusions that as you say will be very
controversial
the report says that britain is actually
not at all an institutionally racist
country
in any way it says that britain is in
fact the model for
um white majority countries in terms of
the lives of
ethnic minorities um who live in this
country
and it uses the example of education
mainly as the
as to make its argument for this it says
that uh children from
ethnic minorities are more likely to do
well at school than
white british children um obviously
you know this you will you as you can
imagine and this is going to be a pretty
incendiary report that um you know has
sparks
a lot of uh a lot of feeling tomorrow
and we're only we've only just got the
first few extracts of it
uh out coming this evening um i think
it'll be really interesting to see
how this goes down because you know we
saw the outpouring of
feeling last summer in this country uh
throughout through the black lives
matter movement
some may say that this report is is
really glossing over and taking a
pretty positive view of things in this
country and
not perhaps uh getting into the perhaps
some of the issues in the criminal
criminal justice system that we that we
may see uh and how and how that impacts
other minorities
uh with its focus on education instead
and i think um
unfortunately i fear we might be going
down
that little culture wars road again
where there's a little bit of a divide
opens up and we'll
already see it coming out on twitter i'm
sure in the next
in the next few hours are you on the
side of
yeah britain is an open and tolerant and
uh you know fantastic country with
with no problems or really very limited
problems on racism as this report says
or is it actually that you know there
are issues and this report has
overlooked them yes and i mean the
timing is uh interesting too isn't it
just at the start
of the former police officer accused of
murdering george floyd
um you know this that's what sparked it
all at the beginning wasn't it but
you're right there
there is a sense of the rosy glow in the
daily mail commission chairman
tony sewell said the uk had progressed
into a successful
multi-ethnic and multicultural community
which was a beacon
to the rest of europe and the world and
also finding that children from many
ethnic minorities do as well or better
at school than white pupils which was
creating fairer and more diverse
workplaces
telegraph as well racism not always to
blame for inequality
and i think you know that everyone will
digest this and and take
whatever they need from it but that the
headlines here
will really disappoint some people in um
black
asian minority ethnic a term also a
b.a.m.e that they recommend
not using they'll be disappointed won't
they do you think mary
i think so i think um particularly some
of the stories that we're going to come
on to look at um it very much depends on
your perception and your experience
so the report highlighted how historic
cases have created
a deep mistrust amongst certain
communities
and and doesn't attempt to gloss over
that fact at all
um and of course headlines don't give
much room for nuance do they
um i i think that it's quite interesting
that you know
the daily mail i'm splashed with race
revolution which can mean so many things
um but um but that they were um
you know uh uh trumpeting um britain as
as a as a multicultural multi-ethnic
success
you know as as the telegraph said of
course race is not the only
um cause of um socio-economic inequality
and problems and i don't think anyone on
either side would would claim
that so as alex says it it's useful to
have some nuance and perspective and
um as we see the the debate heat up on
twitter
in the coming hours and days perhaps not
to fall completely in one camp
or the other um but but to listen to the
nuance and the complexity
of the of the subject that's being
discussed here well as you said it's
it's not
uh published yet 264 pages it will
definitely be an interesting read
um but as you said uh we go on to the
sun uh which is thierry arne
the legend as the sun describes him
who's decided to take a stand
on social media and partly over racists
and bullies he says
tell us more alex
yeah this is uh tierra marie the former
arsenal footballer who's given a
really quiet and extraordinary interview
to the sun about
why he's had to close down his social
media accounts because
he feels the level of racist abuse that
he's getting is just
something that he shouldn't have to put
up with anymore and this is you know
he's
really just the the last the latest
footballer
in a long line who's had to deal with
this uh on twitter i mean you know
every weekend at the moment um in the
premier league uh footballers uh you
know
if they if they lose a match black
footballers are getting
huge amounts of racist abuse on twitter
and there seems to be very little
that anybody really is trying to do
about it
um and you know there are two things at
play here i mean football
in the premier league is obviously a a
global a global sport not just an
english sport and there are fans across
the world
many of whom who are who are responsible
for for some of this
racist abuse and you know many people in
the premier league would argue certainly
well there's not much that maybe we in
this country can do about some of that
but no doubt a lot of the a lot of the
racism and the bile on twitter is coming
from
from people in this country as well and
there are real questions for social
media
companies to answer over what they're
doing about this and this is one of the
actually one of the key findings in the
in the report which is that
you know while there may be the report
argues at least um
many many improvements in terms of
racism in this country
over the last few years one area where
things have got worse is online and the
fact that you know there is just a
huge amount of uh just awful racism
on on social media that the social media
companies
are doing nothing about so i think we
could probably expect to see from the
government over the next over the coming
weeks and months
more pressure on social media companies
to to try and clamp down on this and
this theory and re-interview will be
probably just the start of that
yes so the rights of ethnic minorities
then in that report the rights of women
to reclaim the streets or wherever was
part of the sarah everard vigil was it
not mary
take us to the metro uh which is that
the police actually
were not or did not operate
inappropriately that night tell us more
about their front page
yeah so an independent body has um found
that police acted
appropriately in in their policing of
the vigil and
while it concludes that there was too
little communication
uh between officers um that um they
they acted entirely appropriately and
within the law and the police union has
hit out at
you know armchair critics of policing
tactics i mean that stands at odds
with the photographs your um and the
footage you're showing right now
um and this independent report um
does know that um the vigil uh was
it was a pr disaster for the police um
uh in in no uncertain terms but um
argues that actually the police acted
completely inappropriately within the
law
and again here i think that um there's a
question of trust
and perception which goes to the heart
of this which i think
this report somewhat ducks um the
context in which people understand the
policing to uh to have taken place and
to have happened and what they see
on their screens and on social media is
is part of what needs to be um
considered here because policing is is
by consent and
police need to build trust within
communities in order to be able to
police effectively
yes and the suggestion was uh from many
people still
that the police could have handled this
difference differently this was a
vigilant protest about the way that
women were treated
after a serving police officer was
accused of murder
the juxtaposition of all of that made it
made this difficult scenes to watch i
suppose
alex
oh yeah absolutely and i think you know
there was polling that came out in the
in the wake of the
of the events at clapham common uh um in
the week afterwards that showed that
you know a lot of the british public
most of the british public were pretty
uncomfortable
with with the actions of the police and
thought that they were heavy-handed so
whatever this report has found i'm not
quite sure
the police have the confidence of the
public on this
i mean one thing that i found
particularly sinister really in this in
this report that came out from the
uh in inspector today is that the thing
that they seem most concerned about was
that lots of people on social media were
saying that crested
dick the metropolitan police chief
commissioner should resign and she'd
handled things
so badly and the police were you know uh
were way over the top and this report
says
all of these people on twitter and
journalists and politicians who were
saying that she should resign
were the ones that to blame for the
police's reputation with the public
worsening well i think i mean it's a bit
strange that
police not only that they want to shut
down this vigil it now seems that they
want to sort of shut down
pretty mild criticism and pretty stand
the journalistic behavior and behavior
of politicians and
slightly worrying that the police would
want to
protect their own in such a way and try
to sort of
close down what is really an absolutely
necessary political debate about how
policing in this country works
i think that is for me the main takeaway
from this report
which i think again it shows is another
example of as the police as the report
says a bit of a pr disaster from them
yes um that's interesting because the
police were saying at least hear our
side of the story
before you comment i suppose that was
their criticism towards politicians um
from what i heard today
um plenty more still to come including
emmanuel macron
and angela merkel turned to vladimir
putin for help with the coveted vaccine
we'll have more on that after this break
mary let's go to the daily telegraph
shall we now their lead
story uh is that the french and german
governments look to be turning to
the russians for their vaccine uh
sputnik v which to be fair has been very
well reviewed but
for me this has got all sorts of
geopolitical interest um
that they go there uh what's the
telegraph saying about this
well i mean it's vaccine diplomacy isn't
it on on putin's part
um this is another engine of uh well
it's a it's
a diplomatic victory really for him um
you know
there's a sort of arms race around
around vaccines and the germans um have
decided after
um reviewing the astrazeneca vaccine um
to halt it for the under 60s so there's
an opportunity
um for other suppliers and other world
powers to come in and occupy the space
that um
the astrazeneca vaccine which is of
course one of britain's um
great triumphs um to occupy and and so
yes it's it's very much um geopolitics
um
power play um and you know yes it the
vaccine is is
uh had good reviews and it seemed to be
very effective um but it's
interesting this this shift and um very
notable that the telegraph
are reporting on their front page
absolutely i mean some nations i think
like hungary have already gone there
haven't they so it's gonna
be interesting to see how that goes down
with uh with brussels and the rest of
the european union
uh in the meantime alex let's move on to
the metro she says guessing it is the
metro i think isn't it
and what you can see on google street
view this is a good one isn't it
yeah this is easily the best story in
tomorrow's newspapers i reckon um
incredible story of property hunters
clicking on right move to look at a 375
000 pound house in west sussex looks
lovely three double bedrooms
uh south facing garden absolutely
brilliant you click on a link on
right move to see where exactly it is
you click on that and it
takes you to the google street view and
what do you see a load of armed police
with machine guns
raiding the property and arresting
arresting a load of people inside
absolutely uh incredible incredible
scenes of what you see on group google
street view i think people
when they're when they're buying a house
quite often would think well why is the
why is the previous owner
owner leaving i think this few would
expect uh
quite this to be the answer the article
finishes
with the line a man was later jailed for
possession of a defensive woman
weapon and a woman and a teenage boy
were also sentenced for possession of a
blade so there you go there you go i
just want to know if they bought the
house but maybe not after that
who knows alex wickham mary fitzgerald
we'll see you from what half 11 thank
you so much